The Fallout from the Johnny Deb Amber
herd trial continues and now its effects
are even reverberating Under the Sea
well kind of here's what fans have
learned from court filings about the
behind the-scenes tension on Aquaman and
the lost kingdom things haven't been
great for the DC extended Universe
lately and the same can be said for
Aquaman and the lost kingdom star Amber
herd after Blue Beetle bombed at the box
office the DCU is riding a four movie
failure train toward the Aquaman sequel
meanwhile herd has spent much to the
last few years in the series of Highly
public legal battles with former partner
Johnny Deb as the side ofe era is
nearing its end both herd and the dceu
would no doubt welcome a win however
potentially muddying the waters for both
is a new report by variety which
contains some serious and occasionally
strange allegations about the production
and its treatment of herd we should
point out that the Variety article
doesn't contain direct quotes from herd
or other named parties instead much of
its information stems from notes that
were taken taken by her therapist Dr
Dawn Hughes during sessions as well as
unnamed industry sources these files
first surfaced on Reddit in September
after Deb's fans paid for the release of
court documents it's also worth noting
that because the article was published
during the ongoing 2023 sag after a
strike neither herd nor Mamoa can
currently address the allegations to the
press this means that at present there's
no way to know for certain what was or
wasn't said when these notes were taken
according to the article's allegations
multiple people behind Al man and the
lost kingdom including director James ju
wanted heard out because of her legal
battles sometimes you have to do what's
right even if your heart aches against
it the biggest bombshell in the new
allegations are the notes implying that
Aquaman two star Jason Mamoa wanted to
get rid of Amber herd and was very much
against her to the point of taunting her
while dressed like Deb these notes
alleged that herd described Mamoa as
quote drunk late on set and dressing
like Johnny Deb no no these allegations
are in clear conflict with earlier
claims that Mamoa fought to keep her in
Aquaman 2 in all likelihood we'll have
to wait until the SAG after strike ends
before mamo's people comment on the
situation but for the time being
insiders have vly denied these
allegations stating that herd and Mamoa
had a good relationship on the set One
Source said Jason works his ass off
likes to have a beer once in a while
like everyone but doesn't show up drunk
to set and he isn't dressing like Johnny
Deb he has always dressed in the
Bohemian style a DC representative has
also denied the allegations and praised
mimo's professionalism similarly the
shudio was also denied the allegations
against James 1 a spokesperson told
variety James is known for treating
members of his cast and crew with the
utmost respect and for fostering a
positive collaborative environment on
set the Aquaman films were no exception
according to multiple sources Warner
Brothers wasn't originally going to
include Amber herd in Aquaman and the
lost kingdom citing chemistry issues
with mimoa
strangely enough the notes alleged that
the reason she ended up in the movie was
none other than herd's former partner
Elon Musk who contacted Warner Brothers
and threaten litigation should her not
be part of Aquaman 2 I'm going to kill
Aquaman and destroy everything he holds
dear however all of this reportedly
happened in 2018 and was unconnected to
the her de trial due to the timing of
the Variety article Mamoa herd and other
parties may only be able to comment on
the news extremely belatedly if at all
musk hasn't shared his version of the
event either as such there's a chance
that the notes and the allegations they
contain will resurface in the news
somewhere
[Music]
Downstream